a
sí
a mitad del mes de julio pasado haití
recibió 500.000 dosis de vacuna en el
programa o bucks de ms las vacunas
disponibles hoy en haití son modernas y
johnson johnson y son gratuitas desde
que empezó la campaña de vacunación hace
un mes más o menos
24.000 personas fueron vacunadas y 500
días decidieron sus dos dosis hay que
recordar que haití tiene una población
de 12 millones de habitantes por ahora
las autoridades llegan a vacunar más o
menos 1.000 personas cada día en los 50
centros de vacunación que cuenta el país
17 de ellos se encuentran en puerto
príncipe
la prioridad es para profesionales de
salud de gente de tercera edad y
personas que viven con
comorbilidades hay que mencionar al
final que barrios de los haitianos
tuvieron que viajar en el extranjero
para ser vacunados
[Música]
o
a más de 5 meses de la aplicación de la
primera vacuna contra el coi 19 en
paraguay la campaña de vacunación avanza
muy lentamente hasta ahora 2 millones
200 mil paraguayos y residentes
extranjeros
recibieron al menos una dosis de la
vacuna
esto representa cerca del 30 por ciento
de la población total de 7 millones 300
mil habitantes de las personas
inmunizadas unas 600.000 están esperando
una segunda dosis las dos principales
causas de este lento avance son por un
lado una escasez de vacunas y una
deficiente gestión del gobierno a la
hora de adquirirlas hay que decir que
70% de la vacuna que llevan a paraguay
son productos de donaciones de gobiernos
extranjeros y por otro lado una
reticencia por parte de un importante
sector de la población hacia las vacunas
según el ministerio de salud un millón
600 mil personas esto representa el 35
por ciento del público objetivo de la
campaña de vacunación no se inscribió
para hacer alguna a pesar de estar en el
rango de edad para hacerlo
[Música]
según el ministerio de salud unos tres
millones de hondureños de los siete
millones elegibles ha recibido al menos
su primera dosis de vacuna anti kobin en
las últimas horas se ha montado la
quinta jornada de vacunación donde se
pretende inocular a unos 200.000 jóvenes
con la vacuna facer gracias a un lote
que ingresó al país como parte del de
los 4.4 millones de unidades compradas
por el gobierno a esta farmacéutica el
resto de la población se ha logrado
vacunar con donativos provenientes de
gobiernos amigos sin embargo de acuerdo
al colegio médico el resto de la
población sobre todo aquellas de zonas
rurales todavía no tiene acceso a una
vacuna y todavía hay muchos hondureños
pendientes de la segunda dosis esto
mientras la enfermedad sigue en ascenso
de acuerdo a datos oficiales ya son ocho
mil quinientos muertos por esta
enfermedad y la cifra de contagiados
sigue en ascenso
[Música]